this video is sponsored by the great
courses plus
people are tired strafed by life
mutilated either by love or no love
people are not good to each other one on
one
people are just not good to each other
we are afraid
we think that hatred signifies strength
that punishment
is love charles bukowski
it takes no more than a dog barking a
little too long or person moving around
a little too loudly
while we were in a wretched mood that we
didn't choose to feel a visceral
reminder of the non-rhythmic disorder
always around and in us to feel a world
that is propelled and shared with
innumerable other beings
all wanting it to sound and move as if
it were their own
just as much as we do all struggling
over such an impossibility
we know that we aren't the center of
everything we learn that hopefully
sometime in very early adolescence
however despite this
each inevitable disillusioning
experience can inject us with
at least to some degree a sense that we
have been singled out
that we have personally and
intentionally been given a misery or
frustration
that requires blame or answer of course
some of the time this is the case
but how often do we confuse the faults
of being in general with the faults of
other people and things specifically
how often do we confuse the anxiety and
confusion and plight of all humankind
with our own everyone is experiencing
the same dissonance of being
living their own story through the
nauseating roller coaster of ups and
downs to nowhere
it is both banal and almost hollow to
say that we should be compassionate and
kind to others because of this
every first grade child knows this in
less words the notion of togetherness
and compassion
is sold to us in soda and fast food
commercials as well as nearly every
disney movie
it is so commodified cliche and obvious
that it's hard to even take seriously
the idea of needing to consider it
further
life isn't a soda commercial nor a
disney movie and it isn't anywhere near
as clean as a first grade child could
likely even imagine there is a world
filled with malevolence and anger
and greed and impatience and all the
rest but because of this very reason
because compassion is so trite and yet
still seemingly so hard and absent
it is perhaps all the more essential and
rational of a serious focus and effort
although it can and at times almost
certainly should be
compassion need not be synonymous with
what might generally be considered
agreeableness
rather the compassion being referred to
here more suggests
a sympathetic understanding of others
lack of agreeableness
an awareness serving to help calibrate
our easily incited impatience
or anger or finger-pointing or disdain
towards others over mostly nothing
or things that we can't really know or
understand
there is a suffering and confusion a
part of existence that we all know and
feel
yet seem to so often struggle to grant
others
to not see the so obviously unobvious
thing behind everything
to hate to seek vengeance to frequently
act on anger
to declare certainty in almost anything
all contradict the very struggle and
confusion of life that we feel such a
pain over in the first place
how often do we turn minor
inconveniences into major ones
over this lack of consideration or worse
yet turn
tragedies of random circumstance into
tragedies of hatred
it's not that if one is annoyed by or
disagrees with another person or group
they shouldn't nor should they not try
to work for what they believe in
or against what they disagree with but
it is perhaps worth approaching all
instances as often as we can with the
awareness that the ignorance and
annoyance and sometimes cruelty we find
in others
is sometimes found by others in us
sometimes at the same time
and with equally valid reasons who is
right in such a case
perhaps in some of them no one is and
perhaps not even the person who thinks
they've trumped such an occurrence
by realizing it's happening and
determining that they are superior to
both parties
by realizing how foolish both are even
here
if one acts in such a way one is
exhibiting a conceit and smugness over
others by thinking that they have
superiorly realized the foolishness of
being conceited and smug
everyone is absurd and their attempt to
trump their own absurd relationship with
everything and everyone is all the more
so when they do not realize that they
even here are also a part of everyone
there is but one thing that seems to
have any positive effect against such
absurdity
a sort of compassion for the whole an
understanding that everyone is in it
and everyone is flailing against it for
the same reasons as everyone
else and thus within limits perhaps
everyone deserves such a consideration
and compassion
of course there are actions and people
that exist in a category that warrant
harsh scrutiny
and proper handling like all things
there are cases that reside further out
in the extreme
where the lines become blurrier and the
response less obvious
but it could be argued that a certain
compassion is still applicable
even if a conflicting response is
necessary ultimately there is a movement
in this world with no one in the
driver's seat
everyone dealt different complex nuanced
hands of good and bad
luck all of which causes everyone to be
who they are and
aren't at bottom no one chooses who they
are born as
and no one chooses everything that
happens thereafter but ultimately
everything forms what one is in the
words of schopenhauer
man can do what he wills but he cannot
will what he wills
as always none of this is to make light
of the colossal difficulty of
accomplishing such a thing
being not only aware of but also acting
in accordance to such a compassion
is an incredibly hard and constant
effort most likely impossible in the
complete sense
and because it's so hard a great number
of people don't
and since a great number of people don't
it's only exponentially harder
for most if not all of us it is an ember
that is perpetually on the brink of
burning out
but also for most if not all of us we
are constantly teetering
in and out of being the one that is in
need of compassion and understanding
and with every insight and consideration
with every moment of self-reflection and
temperance
there is an opportunity to influence a
slight change in the cycle
even if it's just in us to use our
awareness of our unawareness
as a source of compassion and
understanding for others and ourselves
as opposed to a source of disdain and
bitterness to use our unique
conscious position to know how hard it
is to be in a conscious position
and to acknowledge that everyone else is
in fact
also in one
this video was sponsored by the great
courses plus
maintaining a lifelong education of
diverse and high-level subjects
is of course very important but can be
fairly difficult to do so on one's own
the great courses plus is an on-demand
video learning platform
that makes this much easier by providing
a library of over 11 000 reliable
insightful and well-organized video
lectures offering courses in literature
history science philosophy as well as
more niche subjects like arts
media personal development and much more
the great courses plus covers mostly
anyone's interests and curiosities
with content provided by professors from
ivy leagues and top universities around
the world
as well as experts from places like
national geographic
the great courses plus allows you to
learn on your own terms without
compromising
depth and quality if you're interested
in learning about different topics
related to psychology and human nature
a great course is entitled your
deceptive mind
a scientific guide to critical thinking
skills which goes into a wide breadth of
topics related to things like the
formation of beliefs and perceptions
logical fallacies cognitive flaws and
critical thinking or the lack thereof
you can start your free trial today by
visiting thegreatcoursesplus.com
slash pursuit of wonder or by clicking
the link in the description below
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video